concentric circles of course but i'll
explain it one way and there's probably
other ways to think about this as well
um in my eyes the business analyst is
there every day
trying to respond to the questions at
hand for the day or the week uh or maybe
the two weeks
most of the stuff that they are working
on is going to be
relatively one-off right hey can you
help me figure out this carrier problem
this week can you help me figure out why
a vendor isn't shipping on time this
week
and then
those insights or those discoveries
ultimately we want to be able to do that
in a repeat fashion
so i kind of see that's where the
technical problem solvers can bring
their
more technical skills in and say oh
that's great that we found that let's do
that over and over again
um so right business analysts more ad
hoc one-offs and then the technical
problem solvers we're trying to scale it
up and make it repeatable
with that said
the technical problem solvers also
sometimes are working on ad hoc but
maybe
we need to figure out how many yard
spaces do we need in our yards because
we're going to have the highest volumes
that target has ever pushed through our
supply chain network this fall
should we get additional off-site yard
space at some yards so
yeah again concentric circles but that's
a little bit of the differentiation that
i see